playing only X home turkey turkish flag
and it's an IM to 263 rated and what is
it a king's indian no probably getting a
bureaucracy bind or some sort of a
modern defense yeah d5 now leads to the
the Benoni yeah the Benoni is not not
too bad for what is delaying the caption
to now play five clothes in the center
so we have a closed center position
where black is some playing for this
standard f5 idea it's some interesting
yeah there are various ways to to play
that can try to capture on f5 and play a
for this is one idea i can also even
play g4 sometimes you can do that but
that doesn't look too too right at the
moment here
yeah and I want to play with their form
takes a net forum this is interesting
the question is where to put the bishop
hmm gap it both has sides points okay
let's go here you can take hace 3 now
this is some an interesting idea doesn't
see me he wants to it's well it's very
often just good I mean not just
interesting it's an old idea of Tigran
Petrosian to capture here on c3 in the
king's indian Petrosian really rarely
played the king's indian but he had some
some games with it so what I'm trying to
do is I need to openly locate pieces
here trying to get the Queen out of a
camp and in the long run I'd like to
play g-form ok don't want to see be five
plate yeah well that isn't such a
problem actually there a four was a bit
what was a bit too quick wasn't I wasn't
necessary to do that yeah why not here
attacking a seven so
it's g4 and he can take h3 I know but
this also entails some risk yeah it is
it is an interesting idea if he takes
h3a play g5 try to play Bishop f1 Bishop
f2 and harassing the Queen besides the
positional compensation that is that is
them also look a 3m group III could be a
possibility small okay Bishop everyone
does Queen to h5 this is not helping
Bishop f2 and roock g3 as a possible
this also okay three maybe rook a three
this is some quite interesting trying a
discovery half of the of the bishop
yeah to be honest I think widest in
excellent shape i also have night takes
d6 which I just spotted 9696 be 65
attacking both nights of course it's a
bit of an untidy position it's not it's
complicated Wow I mean I was thinking
about this anyway besides Bishop takes
d5 this was also possible instantly so
now the queen is hanging and both night
sighing yeah you can take here right and
then take d 6 plus rook takes d3 the
Queen still doesn't have any great
prospects here I think so or g6 gee
thanks that's rookie to
don't jump onto that look it to us
something you don't want to see okay so
go here prepare the should be five
so we just need some precision in this
pill is this position to win how to how
to to do that
maybe a rookie one protecting v5 and
allowing a queen movement I also want
the King out of the corner this is
always cause for concern so just just
Queen h3 now is this it's not completely
winning Queen f3 maybe that's the Queen
g6 okay I can also just take it doesn't
really doesn't really pose a problem
check
I don't mind the endgame of course check
with the extra material he's got two
bishops but my pieces are excellently
placed they all work together nicely now
so I should go here and then look g1
activating yeah yes rook so an IG five
is not good it's better to go here 95 if
he takes on f5 route g7 so this is not
not on k let's let's do that yeah that's
too much e 6 cannot prevent insects
check check check hmm ok so just
promoting isn't it c6 coming check black
resigned yeah i don't know i mean around
here i think black is in trouble but it
shouldn't be it shouldn't be lost and
after a six this is just just lost 96
was an idea even here but probably not
yet working here either something else
night situ was the computer move for
okay this is interesting of course yeah
walking a different take here this Queen
III and this looks ugly for white I'm
very very uncoordinated now they don't
want to give the dark squared bishop but
now a six is really asking for it and
yeah after that white is just winning
alright thanks for watching